but then after that moment what usually
happens is a full realization everything
becomes clear who they are what they are
what they need becomes clear now they
might not win just because you're in the
comedy doesn't mean that your character
is going to succeed in love and death
Woody Allen dies at the end of the movie
he comes back in comments and comments
on it as a ghost but he's still dead but
but that's the point of the movie in
which rep everything has been revealed
all revelations have taken place and now
your protagonist can try to achieve what
they need to achieve what they want to
achieve and and that's the part of the
hero's journey that we call the race to
the finish and and in that race to the
finish success or failure has to hang by
a hair's breath it's always got to be a
situation where it could go either way
believably go either way and in in the
race of the finish your your character
literally has to take action now that
seems like it would be self-evident and
yet I read a lot of screenplays in which
you're a passive protagonist passively
let something happen that passively arm
allows them to succeed in the end and if
they're if there's one thing you need to
do at that moment in the hero's journey
is the character must take positive
action that's why we see Dustin Hoffman
racing to the church that's why we see
Billy Crystal running through the
streets of Manhattan to to tell meg Ryan
he loves her and it doesn't need to just
be a little race I mean in that's enough
with the very soft you know kind of
small soft-spoken comedy with Julia
Louie Dreyfus and the late great James
Gandolfini he's broken up with her
because
he found out that she was trying to keep
the fact that her his ex-wife is her new
best friend and and masseuse client and
he just couldn't deal with the duplicity
and he breaks up with her and what Julia
louis-dreyfus does is she simply drives
by his house and stops outside his house
so it doesn't need to be racing down the
street but it does need to for your
character to take some positive action
to make their dreams come true too to
achieve their goal and then the end of
the comic heroes journey is you don't
necessarily need to have a wedding or
celebration but there has to be some
hint of the future that the future is
going to be set on a better path
you